The Yale Peabody
Museum meteorite collection
♪
is the first meteorite
collection in North America.
It started with the Weston
Connecticut meteorite
that was analyzed and described
by Benjamin Silliman in 1807.
And from that one meteorite,
the collection grew
which puts the Yale
meteorite collection
into the top meteorite
collections in the world.
[sound of drill]
This crate
contains a roof section
from Park Forest, Illinois,
that was hit
by one of the meteorites.
So I don't exactly know how
this fits in here,
but I think it was something
like this
fitting the Tetris model.
This is a slice of the moon
of a meteorite
that was collected in Libya.
Another interesting,
meteorite source that we know
for sure where it comes from
is a piece of the planet Mars.
These are some of the most
spectacular meteorites.
So it's a slice
that if you look at it
against light,
it looks like stained glass.
It is a beautiful piece.
Meteorites
give us the means to understand
the mineralogical, chemical,
physical,
and biological evolution
of the solar system.
The value
of a meteorite collection,
just like the value
of a mineralogy collection
or the value of a paleontology
collection, the scientific value
lies in the fact that new data
can be taken
from these objects
as science makes progress.
It all boils down to curiosity.
That's the key word.
I am a curious individual.
I think most people are curious.
Meteorites are the
only objects that take us
out of the comfort
of our home planet
out into space.
♪♪